hey what's up guys thanks for tuning in
to are you garbage please make sure you
go
subscribe to the youtube channel that
way you get the videos as they come out
yeah do it welcome to another exciting
edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is
r u gabbage the show where we sit down
with your favorite comedians
and fun if they grow up classy or if
they're absolute trash
i'm your host states foley coming at you
on a beautiful day down here
aunt toddy's basement the new studio
could not be happier
coming at you from the heart of midtown
manhattan uh big shout out to our
producer extraordinaire mr toby mcmullen
over there working the ones and two they
don't love you pal
of course my co-host coming at you from
real
close to me a little too close for the
framing of you i've been rocking that
black sweater for a while [ __ ] bruce
wayne over here
gang do me a favor the next time i reach
you for a best pal go ahead and make it
a gippy
he works the ones and twos he [ __ ]
cooks the books he keeps us
all nice and secure kevin james ryan
everybody hey gang what's up everybody
thanks so i love how your [ __ ]
you're commenting on my fashion choices
you've been wearing the same hawaiian
shirts for
[ __ ] six years but the kids the kids
love it
also you can see your legs in last
episode those things are some
big mamma jammas he was wearing his
little short shorts that we're riding up
on ah i've been off in space in it for a
while i got flip-flops on right now your
thighs are like the great white north
those things
jesus christ start calling them things
canada
uh what's up everybody please make sure
you rate review subscribe on itunes full
video available on youtube
subscribe there as well those numbers
are through the [ __ ] roof we
appreciate that
also the big thing is this just in
patreon.com
are you garbage sign up you get bonus
content you get additional videos
additional episodes
uh we just did the first episode on
patreon
and we [ __ ] called our moms we
started off with a bang we
called our [ __ ] moms to find out if
they were garbage
uh news alert they're both trash a
couple of real hooys
a couple of real dumb broads no stranger
to the happy hour you know what i'm
talking about
yeah my mom got a little political it
was a thing
she had a couple of spritzers in her
couple of m's and you know who's getting
thrown around on the line to
uh patreon.com are you garbage you can
sign up you can sign up today and get
all the uh
it's instant access yeah we're like
[ __ ] pornhub
it's an axe i'm not waiting a month well
most bozos make you wait until the end
of the month we get you [ __ ] right in
there mixed up because get in on the
party line because we need the cash
we're [ __ ] i'm hemorrhaging funds
over here familiar with the term working
capital ladies and gentlemen
and also too the [ __ ] uh the merch
store is open
all right podcast podcast
podcastmerch.com
go to ru garbage we have all the new
t-shirts we have the [ __ ] make it a
kippy we have the milkman
which i absolutely love shout out to gns
artwork over there in uh germany
sure did our [ __ ] designs for us you
can get the garbagio you can get the
clean living all right
and we got some [ __ ] hoodies we need
the money
[ __ ] tighten it up will ya gang we
could not be more excited to have our
incredibly special guest here with us
today we have known this gentleman since
jump stream off the [ __ ] streets of
the west village going back at least
seven eight years
uh this young man is a very sexual it's
very successful
yes i am 46 to midnight
sexual i want to suck this dick i'll
tell you that right now
ladies and gentlemen he's a very
successful stand-up comedian actor and
writer
as a comedian you've seen him on gotham
comedy live joking off
and the funny dance show as an actor
you've seen him on new heights
two broke girls school of rock casey
undercover group therapy and the last
conception and as a writer who's wrote
on singled out and group therapy has a
couple jobs coming up that we can't
mention right now but gang
you know him as the host of hq trivia
but the big question in everybody's mind
today is he garbage and we're going to
find out
do me a favor give it the [ __ ] up as i
say
many times many a weekend for the one
hello the only let's go matt richardson
that's
me i'm glad buddy thanks for doing the
show
thank you for having me you have real
haitian rapper vibes going on right now
i don't know what you're talking about i
don't know what you're talking about
i came
damn that the glasses really bring that
together they all got gold on every
[ __ ] extremity
this guy's he's got the rings he's got
the necklace i like to wear my assets
i love it i wish i could pull it off is
that versace that the
the headscarf the do-rag yeah no this is
uh amazon
i'm not familiar with that designer i
got it on prime
prime day do-rag sale that in a couple
episodes of night court box
buddy thank you so much for coming and
saying thank you i'm honored to be here
we wanted to have you on foreign for a
long time we've been trying
plus i i heard you threw it in kevin's
face on saturday night when you brought
him up on his side
dude he's got a lovely podcast that he's
not been on yeah what do you say
wouldn't you have you he's trashing me
to the crescent wouldn't you want to
have your friends on your podcast i'm
like
you're [ __ ] these people all hate
think i'm the biggest jerk off now
it was fun i know it was richard yeah
you were in rare form on saturday night
i was celebrating
the president he wrote he rolled in on a
saturday wearing like a bottle of annie
wearing a four
thousand dollar suit i was like i had a
whole bottle of hennessy
do you know what's crazy that night i
ended with me hugging the toilet
no way really i guess you fell down the
steps before i
happened it happened it's a tricky step
uh joe the manager at the club had to
pick the lock to the bathroom door to
get me out oh
i was out damn like that's scary because
that goes one of two ways
yeah next thing you know the new york
post is there taking pictures no
if they gotta you know if you think
about the property hit the bricks
they're gonna come get you in the
bathroom you know you're in [ __ ] bad
shape i'm not sure
i was peacefully asleep i took my suit
jacket off i made a pillow
dude sleeping on sleeping on a [ __ ]
cold bathroom floor
ain't too shy when you're all [ __ ] up
oh it's great
you got to come get me in the bathroom i
got like 12 needles sticking out of me
no no getting ready to drag me out
anyway that's neither here nor there
buddy we're so happy to have you here
give us
the back story the origin story of matt
richards yeah i think you're a jersey
kid right i was born
[Laughter]
just north of new orleans i grew up
i was born and raised in queens yeah
elmhurst hospital queen's kid
uh
[Laughter]
my mom used to like if i got in trouble
she would run around the house chasing
me showing me her scar like look at what
you did to me
oh my god yeah so that was uh moms do
hold grudges about
[ __ ] yeah he probably [ __ ] up her
tight frame she had going on
she's still glad shout out to moms
uh all right so but then i thought at
some point you were in jersey no
so okay grew up queens right whole life
right mom and dad mom and dad were
married before they had me
shocker um they were very religious we
went to church a bunch
brothers and sisters i have a younger
sister we're like two years apart
all right there you go okay um then
9 11. yeah what happened split up
shortly after okay i blamed al qaeda
thanks a lot yeah now i got two
christmases what the [ __ ]
i'll get you terrorists wait why do you
say 9 11. just as a time frame
that was like two big events in my life
okay
but they had nothing to do with each
other no
911 was just the chance his mom thought
it was an inside job
what his mom's like explain building
seven will you
that's it i'm leaving it had to be some
kind of thermal [ __ ] going on in there
they were inspecting before the days
before
all right your parents get divorced no
yeah they split up and um
what is who goes where where do you stay
where do you go
my sister and i went with mom sure and
uh you know
noah it's rarely your mom's got to be in
bad shape for you to go with the dad
yeah you always go with the mom yeah but
neither of them were in like bad shape
sure yeah
it's just yeah same same hat the same
thing happened fell out with each other
what happens yeah i remember my dad's
like anybody want to come with us he
told all the kids like anybody want to
come with me today we're all like get
the [ __ ] out of here
[ __ ] staying in the house with the
toys [ __ ] fried eggs for dinner
no thanks bozo i'll see you on the
weekend my dad's actually an exceptional
cook
oh really really yeah yeah that would
have been a tough call for me too
mom was on a teriyaki like just every
time
to this day i can't touch teriyaki too
much i get nauseous what lean cuisines
oh just like she would make teriyaki
chicken and teriyaki
salmon and i'm like get the food we're
not asian
why are you doing this to your black ass
kids
i get that you're in a karate video
she'd make us bow before you remember
those who
catch flies with chopsticks you remember
those friends you had when you were
younger that weren't asian but their
parents had a lot of asian [ __ ] to the
point
like they have like a like an asian room
divider and like
asian music playing like yeah what the
[ __ ] did your mom go to japan one time
one time that's what the samurai
in the dining room buddy it was my
grandfather
all the walls are see-through
from the far east all right so your
parents split up you stay with your mom
your and your
queens where'd your dad go dad went to
queens okay in queens so he's right
around the corner yeah and
mom my sister and i moved to jersey oh
really
after um you know she was like figuring
things out we stayed with some family
for a little bit yeah sure
then we went out to jersey city jersey
city wait
do you guys lived in an apartment yeah
well we i grew up in houses
and then after the split it was
apartments right so who kept the house
uh so the thing is i think my
grandfather owned the house
okay your dad's dead my dad's dead all
right
and uh we moved to a another house that
we were renting
and then after the split it was it was
apartment apartment life
right yeah so you moved up to jersey in
an apartment your dad's in queens jersey
was a two family home so it was a house
nice duplex type yeah a little duplex
those are nice
nothing wrong with a dude my high school
girlfriend duplex living i think that's
me
mom my sister my two sugar gliders
you had those wait what i've had sugar
gliders for years yeah so that's
that's the one thing listen listen he is
exceptionally good at it
he is exceptionally uh great
with animals i am pet dad of this dude
has
more [ __ ] pets i challenge anybody to
take better care of their animals than
me he does he
listen okay so it's weird sugar dude the
sugar gliders
sugar gliders they're like flying
squirrels but they're possible i know
dude listen
my buddy i would [ __ ] freak the [ __ ]
out one of my buddies run up i think
still he owns the
distribution rights for sugar gliders in
the united states if you bought it you
bought it from like through him
it's crazy he's like a big sugar guy
he's at the top of the pyramid scheme
yeah for sure wait so this thing this
goes back
since you were a kid uh yeah i might
i've always had pets like dogs and cats
and then
uh i wanted a lizard really bad and my
grandmother got me
an iguana just when you're young when
you had the sugar gliders
before the sugar gliders what age we
talking with the iguana
his name was ziggy i had ziggy when i
was like
seven but before that i had always had a
turtle
i had i was a turtle kid i was a frog
kid too
at frogs turtles everything snakes
my uncle jeff r.i.p was uh a big
influence on my
herpetological studies you are good with
it man i'll give you that
when you when you we're out in l.a and
and your your apartment you had ever you
keep everything tight you keep
everything clean my
apartment i had [ __ ] i had fish tanks
and lizards and birds and [ __ ] it just
i find having something to take care of
keeps me working hard
okay sure but birds dude you can't be
having you have birds now
no i i gave them to my roommate in l.a
i went away for work and when i came
back they were really bonded to her
to the point where they would bite me
really yeah
are they flying around the apartment are
they in the cage desi
learned how to fly on his own and lucy
never uh took off what kind of dude if
you're loose bird people
that's [ __ ] that's
i didn't even make it through the foyer
i was like [ __ ] hit the bricks see
you later
no they're chill man they they would
[ __ ] in the cage and then
not really yeah that's pretty good i'd
be okay with that
no as long as they're not [ __ ] on
the couch and stuff like that yeah
bird [ __ ] really freaks me out no it's
like living on a park bench dude it's
good enough birds that close to you
i was like the old lady from home alone
i can't watch that movie and eat man
that chick grows there's bird [ __ ] on
her shoulder
that's you if you if you like birds by
the way that wasn't even like
set decoration that was actually i know
just [ __ ] pigeon [ __ ] on her it's
good luck i'd ask for more money for
that i'll tell you that
all right go back to the sugar gliders
you guys move out to jersey
you have sugar gliders in an apartment
in my bedroom
what did your mother say i mean i paid
for them
they're paying rent yeah yeah that was
cool i had uh
i had a six by four foot cage
in the corner of my bedroom a six-foot
cage
yeah that was they had their wheel and
like all their toys and [ __ ]
those things are creepy what do they do
they just glide they love you
yeah they just love you aren't they mad
because they can't really stretch their
wings oh
they were out and roaming the house like
when i was home
they'll sit in your pocket they sleep in
these i used to wear them in a pouch
under my school clothes yeah yeah yeah
and just walk around with two sleeping
sugar gliders on my chest off they don't
know
in school yeah nobody i mean i got in
trouble all the time in school for
bringing pets to school i found a kitten
on my way and i had that rolling
backpack [ __ ]
and i put the kitten in my backpack you
were a rolling backpack kid
just because the kitten what are you a
drug rap
kids working for pfizer there was an
evil [ __ ] named chutney
that's like that's like cartoon movie
yeah
so she sat next to me in homeroom and
she kept seeing me go to my backpack to
take care of his kitten
and she's like what's in the bag i was
like none of your business chutney
and then she [ __ ] kicked the backpack
oh what a [ __ ] [ __ ] and i was like i
never hit a girl but i
break your face chunny you are not a
woman somebody touched my kitty cat
the following year she stole my game boy
he's going to be crying if he keeps
telling us these stories this girl just
bullied you all through middle school
i think she liked me but a senior in
high school she stole my heart
and mom shout out to mrs
wait the cat eye the kittens i
understood kitten i understand you
so didn't the sugar gliders get out when
you were in school no they slept all day
yeah they just curl up and they're not
in your pockets and just sleep there
but when they were in the house they
were like doing the whoa jumping around
carpeted the entire side of my bookshelf
so they could run up to the top of the
bookshelf
glide to the bed and they would just do
this like ninja warriors yeah
that's the thing i would i would i want
to say this is all garbage but the way
he does it specifically he's like
he's really really good at it as a
teenager i worked at the reptile museum
in hicksville long island
and i used to stretch tours hicksville
is
shitty place they closed the reptile
museum but it was just your iguana
it's just one everybody stepped right up
right
he was just on the train with his neck
come see
the exotic iguana from florida
all right they closed it down because i
think the owner wasn't taking proper
care he kept
he had a lot of alligators for no reason
yeah those people
how the [ __ ] have an alligator and
[ __ ] long island that's [ __ ] crazy
all right so go ahead so you're you're
you're living in the apartment
in jersey that's where you went to
school all that kind of went to
grade school high school i moved to
jersey after
graduating high school didn't go to
college um
so wait hold on so you so your entire
you growing up you were in queens
yeah oh okay all right all right why did
you
why did you move to jersey after high
school i was touring with a play
and okay it was just easier to keep all
my [ __ ]
at your mom's all right so i was on the
road okay
eight months a year damn so growing up
you were a city kid
yeah nice all right that gives us a
little bit of a picture and your sister
lives with you all the way up until high
school
yeah no college you didn't go to school
because you were touring you were
working as an actor
straight out of school i went on the
road okay
all right that gives us a little bit of
a picture there
i used to like cut high school leave
early to go into the city to sell
tickets for comedy shows
okay yeah you've always been a worker
yeah grinder kid's an earner for sure
yeah i mean that's your point sophomore
year i was making about 600
a day between doing magic on the subway
and comedy ticket sales
really yeah so that's where you're
funding all the animals
okay a little expensive that guy that
was on the i think he was on like the
q train or something the old russian guy
with the oh it's a little the magician
with the
like he's got like a dove and a bird all
like in the car yeah that's my [ __ ]
olaf
really are you serious it's just like
we went to bird school together yeah
what's your hematology
[Laughter]
listen patreon.com
and how many animals before we get into
the questions here
do i have currently no no no yeah i want
to know that now okay
that but growing up because you kind of
you made it seem like
i thought you left uh queens when you
were a little kid
no i was in queens throughout high
school all right graduated from frank
sinatra school of the arts
by the skin it was so cool to me
i don't know is that trash or not what
performing arts school tony bennett
opened it he used to walk the hallways
all the time that's what
tony bennett tony bennett opened the
school in honor of frank that's what
that's what new york has all those
performing arts schools you know it's
like you know
those things are [ __ ] dope frank did
you take your sats
no no you didn't i was i had like four
periods of
theater a day yes ballet and [ __ ] and
our gym was kickboxing class what was
tony bennett like
he was cool he was old as [ __ ] hey matt
good to see you man i don't remember
ever talking to the dude
i just knew him i don't think he was
there every day he was engaged to a man
he was there yeah he come by all the
time
well i guess do a couple of numbers oh
yeah i left my heart
hey gang support for ru garbage is
brought to you today by our new sponsor
manscape baby the best in below the
waist
grooming for men it's the best thing out
there they got the tools for your family
jules if you know
what i'm talking about hit it big man
dude i'm telling you right now
and this is not because it's an ad this
thing is unbelievable
before no listen i'm a bigger guy sure
all right so if things you know if the
front yard's
growing down there there's a lot of
discomfort there's a little bit of odor
there's a little bit of this there's a
little bit of that it's very important
to your daily use you say it dude it
really is and i used to use just the
beard trimmer that i use on my face
but when you're doing that down there
all right it's got the metal blades you
don't know what's going on there's no
guard and and when you when you nick
something down there it stings
yeah it stings for a couple of days and
it's dangerous and listen you only get
one of them things you can't be walking
around with a couple of nicks on it you
know what i mean but dude it's crazy
these guys at manscape they got the
ceramic blade which reduces any kind of
accidents
you know what i mean it has a 90 minute
charger
all right so you got 90 minutes of use
on it they run at 7
000 rpms right how powerful is that but
they use a quiet stroke
which keeps it nice and soft listen so
do i you know what i mean
it's running right now you can barely
hear it and not to mention they have an
led light which is the most important
thing
because you can see where you're driving
down there yeah you're not driving blind
in the middle of the night you know what
i mean
and on top of that the thing's
waterproof you could take it in the
shower
you can clean yourself up nice this
thing is awesome i can't believe
that they sent us one for free this is
unbelievable and i love this thing
yeah it's great so guys trim that junk
of yours if you're a listener of the
show we have a special deal for you
you get 20 off big man what
20 2 zero 20 off and
that ain't done yet and free shipping
when you use the promo code
garbage at manscape.com that's promo
code
garbage at manscape.com that's 20
off and free shipping manscape.com use
promo code garbage
yes sir back to the show shout out to
tony b
shout out to tony b if you like the
smooth sounds of [ __ ]
old school music check out tony bennett
all right let's get in a little are you
garbage here i think we have enough
pictures painted first off let's go back
to kevin's question also
too this is this will be interesting
because you're kind of new money a
little bit you're
you're successful now you know you got
uh you're making a couple of bucks and
you're spending it
which i love i'm investing the [ __ ] out
of it actually sure no i know you're
very smart i mean i've talked to you
about
you know bitcoin and other stuff i do i
do
spend a little too much time i remember
a video i love what you spend it on you
spend it on
you're like it's like it's the ricky
bobby effect you know and it's like tell
you got it now you got money
and you got like he's got like he's got
to motorize one wheel skateboard that he
zips around this is already paid for
itself
of course and the amount of ubers i
don't have to take i remember when you
first got
one of your little uh chunks of change a
few years ago why y'all [ __ ] clock up
y'all setting me up to ride i remember
it was march 14th
i remember when you first started making
money i said i'm gonna get his ass
no you went to your mind i'm gonna start
a podcast in four years and have them
come and then
rob them you went to your mom's work and
dumped money on her that was fun
i just showed up at my mom's job and it
just threw money at him oh my god turn
it into a big pun video made it rain on
my mom
that's awesome what did she say she was
like what the [ __ ] are you doing
she thought she was leaving for good you
were like that's not enough to leave
wait till your break wait do your best
that's enough at least
yeah i love it all right how many pets
do you have now
i got two dogs two cats and a saltwater
fish tank
that's perfectly acceptable it's up
there that's on the high i mean he's
nicer in the judging of it that's up
there for me
four pets in a new york city apartment
it's crazy it's a nice apartment
i'm sure i'm sure it is i'm sure it is
i'm just saying that's a lot
i got a private dog run oh that's pretty
good i'll give you that your dogs are
awesome by the way yes
shout out to thor very nice they're
listening they subscribe
they're on the patreon the pet thing is
it's in the file but like i said it's
you know it's it's nice it's tricky with
you because you're you're excited i
vacuumed five times a day
of course there you go but you do it the
right way it's still a lot of pets
oh yeah oh yeah all right let's go back
a little bit
now you said your mom a lot of teriyaki
what was the what was the name of the
street that you grew up on
okay that i spent most of my time yes
or my formative years it's not the same
thing yeah i don't know to me that's
not anything because what are your form
your formative years formative years are
younger
that's when you're like foreign that's
like elementary school in high school
no i think formative years i don't
[ __ ] know
yeah what is one of them hey siri what
is a formative year
who the [ __ ] is that guy i made my siri
a dude cause i feel weird yelling at her
later
i'm progressive
uh he didn't help no just now what was
it so when you guys moved into the
apartment in queens what was
was the street uh i believe it was
[ __ ] why am i spacing is it a number
it was south conduit avenue south
conduit
avenue that's not too bad that's a new
york street yeah that's gonna be bad if
you were i was like yeah it was the fdr
or whatever
i mean it was damn near the van wyck
expressway it was like that it was like
a highway that
connected queens and long island
i was on the border of queens and long
island that's out there
rosedale it was deep as [ __ ] that's a
lot of buses you take roads
i took the bus from the first stop
to the last stop and the train from the
first stop
to my school did you ever get out there
on that he tried to do that e-training
that that thing goes to [ __ ]
literally if you don't get off of it
i would take the e-train from the city
to the last [ __ ] stop yeah and then
the bus
from the first stop to the left that's a
tough look having to take the train all
the way and then the bus somewhere else
i think
one of our buddies said that he's like
yeah then he just hop on the stop on the
bus
[ __ ] that but then i started uh doing a
long island railroad that was a lot
faster
okay okay all right what was uh
what was the name of the grocery store
your parents went to growing up
associated
i think that's a nice one yeah that's a
nice product no no no
i don't think has ever been associated
yeah there's one i shopped at one up
until like two months ago yeah in the
city maybe
nice yeah it wasn't i mean i mean i've
been in where it was no it wasn't a key
food i'm not getting the oysters
it was it was like a key food okay
kind of they were always playing like uh
freestyle music
[Laughter]
i went in for a frozen pizza i came out
with rice and beans [ __ ]
going in the mood got a soccer shirt on
yeah that's good stuff all right
associated
um would make dinner when you were a kid
your mom would mom would
would do dinner you're gonna sit down
and have dinner it'd be mom or dad
on any given night uh but once we were
with mom
it was mom and would you sit down at the
table or would you guys
instead of sit around the couch and
watch tv ah we would do
well let me i'm trying to remember these
were like
yeah we'd sit in the living room watch a
movie
okay but then as we all got a little
older you know high school age i was
just
going into my room really dinner in the
room
yeah that's kind of weird that's gonna
have to go that's in the file
in the file garbage your mom makes
dinner you come home
you make yourself a place i wasn't
getting home though until
long after dinner was uh so growing up
when you were like a kid kid and the
family was still together oh yeah we sat
at the table all right
you weren't allowed to eat in your room
then no and i will say this
i shared a room with my sister we had
bunk beds and the sugar gliders
that was before the sugar club isn't
there something to be said though
when you do come home a little bit later
when dinner's over
all right and and but it's still sitting
out and like you know it's wrapped up
it's on the stove
it [ __ ] tastes so much better it's
been marinating
i don't know why i love that you go home
you can still smell a little dinner
cooking it's like eight nine o'clock
that's why i was i always try to explain
this on the podcast i was always jealous
of my dad
if he came home later and didn't eat
with us he would come home and like fix
his plate
and by you know be like three hours
after dinner so i'd be hungry again
and like just the way he like the dad
would your dad set it up
it just looks so [ __ ] dad's know how
to eat man do man little pepper little
salt
[ __ ] clancy that was the way yeah
[Music]
all right uh let's switch uh let's
switch gears that brings up one that
i've had that i didn't have down for you
but that brings it up
uh do you currently what's your pepper
shaker do you have like the grinder or
do you have the dumper i have a grinder
okay
that's class yeah i have if you have one
like you stole from a denny's or
something that's a tough look
i don't know i ordered a salt and pepper
yeah on prime day
anybody any if if if you're like you
know around
our age right now and you're living on
your own and you don't have a fresh
pepper grinder that's i'm stressed i
cook though i
so i love i love being yeah there's no
need to have the [ __ ] little metal
mccormick [ __ ] pepper things anymore
this ain't the [ __ ] 80s oh i have we
have one as back up
oh yeah yeah just in case you run out of
the pepper what i mean who's keeping the
pepper the peppercorn in their house
this guy's big on pepper yeah we have a
bottle of peppercorn in there
all right well i'm saying if we just
bought a two-pound bag of
jesus christ it's a it's a seven
peppercorn what are you doing emeril
lagasse
bam just whole peppercorn
he's pepper i break him up with my teeth
when i chew that's pretty good
um let us see this when you go to the
grocery store
when it comes to like uh maybe dairy
products or things like that
do you take the first one or do you take
the second one behind it
i usually take the first one first one
in
yeah because i know a lot of people
trashy people myself included
i'll never take the first one why i
don't know we feel like the
the first one there's something wrong
with it people have been touching it we
always take the second one behind
yeah because you're you have such trash
in your dna you think oh he's out to get
you for some reason are you the guy that
goes to the handicapped stall because
you think it's cleaner
oh yeah yeah that's the dirtiest one
yeah
plus it's bigger that's the one
everybody goes to because they think oh
i haven't seen anybody
yeah [ __ ] here yeah i always handicap's
always bigger i like to stretch it out a
little bit i go first stall
really nobody talks to that one yeah
that's smart
all right well we're on the subject
that's too much heat coming in you're
walking
i'm putting my shoes on there's a lot of
the backs there's a lot of foot traffic
at the first stall wait hold on really
sometimes wait say that again like it
depends on where i'm shooting but
like generally if if i know it's a high
traffic bathroom i'll kick my feet up
against the wall
why you're [ __ ] it's comfortable
that's insane you can [ __ ] laying down
it's like a squatty potty i guess that
kind of makes sense
i couldn't do that um i leaned my head
against it when you
you were so you going to the first stall
right yeah it's uh
how do you clean the toilet seat all
right see if they don't have one of
those
the toilet napkin rings yeah will you
use that you'll lay that down
okay yeah yeah yeah you don't get any
spreadage hold on let them mix
all right all right sorry he's a big guy
i need that
a lot there's a lot of there's a lot of
meat down i need to punch this
spilling over the sides of the toilet he
takes up two stalls actually
one cheek per time so you go in if
there's no if there is no ring
no paper ring what do you do well now
that i'm carrying like little sanitizers
sometimes i might do a little square
squirt and a little wipe down
that's smart but okay before no you know
sand sanitizer
just white paper yeah foley puts uh
that takes a roll of toilet paper dips
it in the water then wipes it
in the toilet water then wipes that on
the seat
after i've flushed it a couple of it
doesn't matter i
so here's the thing that i do that i
don't know that's since that's insanity
if i don't
like if i see the okay there's no
visible droplets of pee
i'll take a little bit of toilet paper
and then like fold it and put it on that
uh
like the where the dick would go that's
that's a pro move
just oh yeah so you get no rubbish
100 of the time i do toilet condoms i've
had that where my little my pee pee
touches that and i'm like god what is
that my little pee-pee
had to be a big toilet to get there
though when i [ __ ] my dick touched the
water i don't have that problem
mine's looking right at me mine's in the
mine's only air baby skydiving
[Laughter]
sometimes sometimes i'll i'll sit down
and
then i'll pee and the pee will come out
the like
between the thing yeah that's gonna
point it down
there's a lot of pressure coming from
the center out all right
yeah my my dick looks like it's like
looking out the window of an airplane
just like
like that it's not not a good look yeah
i don't think anybody thought it was
going to be a [ __ ]
a hell of a nice piece on you by the
right nah i know he's a
huge idiot but you should see his piece
all right let's keep moving along i'm
not the one on trial here goddammit
uh have you ever taken a picture with
your barber
i actually because that's trash i have
actually but here's why
i had so i had to go back to queens to
vote
that's so funny i didn't change my uh my
address on my voter registration
and since i was in queens i went by the
guy that used to cut my hair when i was
like in high school dispatch and uh
he gave me a cut and i was like yo let's
get a selfie dog i
take a picture with you in a minute it's
good to see you i'll give you that
that's a little yeah yeah yeah that's a
little bit different
make sure yeah i hadn't seen the dude in
10 years
but i see people posting pictures with
their barber on the regular i took it
and didn't post it because i looked
weird in it
but i have it on my phone all right i
got one have you ever had a ring back
tone
yes no wait that's when people call you
please wait while your party is reached
and then like you know
i've always wanted really dude that [ __ ]
is you are not fielding any
any good calls i did use that buy
ringtones on jamaica avenue
yeah somebody what do you mean there was
there was a dude that used to sell
ringtones i didn't know
how did you buy them i wasn't tech savvy
enough to
download the song and then cut it so he
would send you the song or whatever i
would go
to his cell phone repair shop this
little kiosk
in like a mall and he charged a dollar
per ringtone
that ain't bad and so i would just give
him five bucks and he would put like
this is on my next tail when everybody
had to turn back baby
and he would put the shits on my phone
so and i just i'd be walking around with
like
ballin big dude
no lie at some point every dirtball had
that as a ringtone you never got into
that
i mean you were 32 when that song
i missed so many calls because of
ringtones
[Laughter]
you know this wait were the next tell
ones the walkie-talkie
how far did they go like for anywhere
oh really nationally yeah oh so wasn't
so you could literally just
talk on a walkie-talkie to somebody
across the coast so you know
you're saving money on the call yeah it
was mo it was like well
that was big and then when i remember
motorola i remember those yeah that was
like the construction workers phone you
know what i mean
because you know it's easier to
communicate or whatever but then
everything went that was before you
couldn't call um
they charge you if i called if we had
the same provider then it was free
within providers and they're going yeah
we don't need to have these [ __ ]
conversations out loud you can just
pick up the phone because you were still
charged for minutes and phone calls at
that time yeah
talking [ __ ] was clutch that was like
yeah ten dollars a month or whatever
it was i remember having phone sex via
chirp what
this is garbage as [ __ ] we were 15.
that's as hot as [ __ ] and it's out loud
too
well then her dad took the phone
[Laughter]
you want a what i went asian
[Laughter]
uh once how was it not for you
awkward yeah yeah i've done it a couple
come on
i mean i worked at one i've done it a
couple times i was 18
the rest of my cast was like 20
23 and up and so they would all go out
to
bars and clubs when we would be on the
road so i spent a lot of time in the
hotel alone
yeah uh
this is gonna bite me in the ass i
called uh
called an escort from
orlando
she came to my villa and played
playstation with me
nerd yeah right i didn't hear an alert i
didn't want to have sex with her i just
i was
and she was like you don't have to pay
me for this i was like no a deal's a
deal
you want to figure my butt or anything
like that no thank you
bye can you put some clothes on this is
awkward i'm trying to do a fatality and
your titties
are all out and about i actually ended
up meeting up with a girl that i would
like i didn't i did not the way she
described herself i'll be honest with
you
oh you got catfish catfish we got i got
[ __ ] dolphins
and she got wailed all right we're
having fun
[Music]
we called a stripper in north carolina
or south carolina myrtle beach that's
how trash we are we got one to the hotel
like we came back from the bar all
[ __ ] up we're like
let's call this stripper to come to the
hotel and then they were like oh
we're you know we're an hour and a half
away and we're like whatever we're still
like
but then you know it's like three
o'clock in the morning you start fading
quick that battery life starts dropping
real fast how are you an
hour and a half away dude it's myrtle b
i don't know who the [ __ ] knows
i mean we were that i think we were you
know scraping the bottom of the barrel
too
we're going after the blue chips i went
to a weird strip club in dillon south
carolina oh
any town named after a guy is yeah come
on over to chad you're like what the
[ __ ]
we show up dudes wearing a flannel with
cut off sleeves
and he's just playing pool by himself it
was me and my boy joseph reese
that was the tripper no he goes he boys
from out of town
you guys want the girl
i was like let's leave yeah he's like no
this is going to be an amazing story
it wasn't i was not it was not an
amazing story at all
barbie doll had uh minimal teeth
and she smelled that was the first time
i smelled crack cocaine
ah hmm good for her
[Laughter]
all right do you currently have a
storage unit
yes okay it's gonna be
garbage put that one down as garbage
right there fair enough
have you ever oh sorry can i defend of
course please if i may sure
uh for a while i was paying rent on the
east coast and the west coast because i
kept my apartment out there
okay go back okay um
and then when hq became a more permanent
part of my life
okay i packed up the la apartment put
everything into storage
that's that's what i'll give you that's
what i'll give you people do i have a
[ __ ] ton of [ __ ]
tanks and lighting and all right [ __ ]
more animal [ __ ] yeah i'll give you that
one
okay have you ever seen your parents
fight someone paid the bill in six
months
he's gonna be on storytellers you're
shaking
yeah we got a sugar glider tank in there
that's 40 bucks right there
yeah somebody's going to come up some
magic [ __ ]
oh there is magic [ __ ] in there kippy i
like that question
yeah have you ever seen your parents
fight someone together
no and or like has your your mom ever
gotten a scuffle or like a tj max or
your dad at a little league game or
something
no my mom did yell at a homeless woman
about pizza
what about it uh my mom was on her way
home from work
i was on my way home from school so she
was like hey well i had already gotten
home she was like yo i left like
uh 30 bucks go grab a pizza and some
wings bring it back
it's like all right cool so i go to pick
up the pizza as i'm walking back to the
uh to the crib there's a homeless woman
and she's like hey can i have a slice of
your pizza
and i was like um my hands are full i
got i'm
i don't want you to touch it yeah no
offense
like no disrespect i would happily give
you a piece and my mom is walking from
the railroad
and she's like she's like hey is
everything all right i was like yes she
wanted a slice of the pizza and my mom
was like oh don't worry sweetie i'll
kill you
was it two two dollars she's like here
i'll give you two dollars throwing
something extra you get yourself
something to drink
and the woman's like i want a slice of
yours oh
yeah and she's like that is for my
children uh-huh
get real i'm giving you my lioness on
them your own slices yeah okay
and she's like but what if i don't like
it and my mom's like what if you don't
like the pizza that's with my kids
huh you taking food out of my kids mouth
and
they just went back and forth jesus and
the pizza got cold
i'll never forget that day oh that's
funny i almost saw my mom get her ass
kicked
really almost like so there's this fat i
think i'm gonna
mention this family moved in from like
philly moved into the suburbs yeah the
bruisers yeah
they had it was like a [ __ ] slip and
fall or something they made a bunch of
money like they weren't
they weren't cut out for you know they
were definitely new money they were
tough kids and the
sun hit me in the head with a hockey
stick i went down my brother went out to
beat him up the older brother beat my
brother
were you playing hockey yeah yeah oh
okay
i was like that's scary i was walking to
school
and the ninja turtles ran by and then my
mom went over to be like your [ __ ]
kids are you know what the [ __ ] and then
she was
screaming out the one i'm gonna come
down there and kick her i was like all
right get back in the car man
i'm like they're not taking out the
whole family leaving a little [ __ ]
dignity
holy [ __ ] yeah that's [ __ ] true
have you ever seen your parents fight
anybody little league game or something
um
i've honestly never seen them i've seen
maybe my dad almost get into a fight at
softball games
[ __ ] that that and like i would [ __ ]
your dad
[Laughter]
i would run through the foley's light
work son um
they used to maybe almost get in fights
with like the other team
that's a real trash i've never oh yeah
yeah
i've never seen them uh i've never seen
them like get into
like an argument i've seen my mom lose
it maybe a couple of times at like a
grocery store or something like that
but never never anything she never
almost got beat up by the neighbors if
that's what you're asking my dad almost
my dad almost fought a dude and
uh uh act me like not that long ago like
within the it was probably like seven
years ago because the guy cut in front
of him in line my dad's like you gotta
i'm like you gotta [ __ ] tone it down
i gotta stand up for that [ __ ] started
uh doing like security and and bouncing
after
my parents split up mm-hmm and i
remember he didn't come home one night
because well i think it was before they
split up he started bouncing but he uh
he didn't come home one night because he
got jumped damn
yeah some dude he kicked the drunk guy
out of the bar
somehow the drunk guy gets back in my
dad's not paying attention and the dude
cracks him over the head with a ketchup
bottle
that's gotta be scary too because you
see the ketchup everywhere you think
you're [ __ ] bleeding
yeah never mind never mind let me get
some fries 57
varieties that's trash you hit somebody
like a gentleman you hit somebody with a
beer bottle yeah it should be a
budweiser box ketchup [ __ ]
yeah ketchup disrespectful hitting
somebody with a man that's what you do
at a diner dude that's not [ __ ]
playing i think he was just trying to
tap the
57. she couldn't get it out yeah i
wasn't stuck let me hit you okay
i had to play the tots he needed to
[ __ ] juice up uh slurpees or icees
ah slurpees are 7-eleven icees
everywhere else yeah
i mean i've had my share of isis okay
pretty clear the seven elevens are dirty
so anything seven elevens are dirty it's
not charlie
listen seven ravens are trash no
it's not true name one seven eleven in
new york that's not trash
well just everything every single one is
disgusting
i went to a 7-eleven the other day
around the corner from the new new york
comedy club yeah
and the dude sang to me while i picked
up oh dude that one's like [ __ ]
downtown beirut that one is bad really
yeah you talking about the one on 23rd
street the one on 23rd
and the one and the one on the fifth
avenue i saw a couple i saw dudes just
stealing the beers locked up in that one
that's how you know it's not good you
have to get a key to get that i know
it's like the medicine at a [ __ ]
for all the black hair care products
wait they have them locked up and they
keep all that [ __ ] ah it's [ __ ] up
it's [ __ ] up
by the way dude they know who's
meanwhile herbal essence is right up
front you can
help yourself
they put a lot on all the hoodies
they're not touching the v05
they got to sell some blue out front
like shut up melon [ __ ]
one of the reasons i think i'm bald is
because i use i only use mary's and dax
for like [ __ ]
12 years i won't make why i'm trying to
get waves you know it just
held up my hair perfectly and dude the
best is you put a little bit of mary's
in then you shout like two days later
that's when you get like the really
good dude it's like vaseline that [ __ ]
don't come out it's like [ __ ] beeswax
dude it's
in there for like a week same can i last
you [ __ ] 10 years you would use some
black hair care products
yeah it was going to school in north
philly that's all i could get my hands
on
murray's is it was like 99 cents a jar
can't be walking around with a wave cap
i can see it
i can see it too man now i'm just
picturing you with like
full-on weight waves in my head looking
like tsunami hit it son
boom how do you feel
right now this has been a big thing on
the podcast for the last couple of days
how do you feel about bacon
cooked in the microwave
i mean i've done it as a youth yeah as a
youth
interesting like i was
you know if you high as [ __ ] you need
bacon immediately yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so if i can get you gotta be
in at the windows getting popped with
bacon grease while high is not
fun yeah it feels worse um
now i would never yeah forever pretty
classy answer
i throw it on the [ __ ] i got i got a
griddle in the [ __ ] skillets and all
that
okay i'll do it in the oven if i'm
pressed for time okay and i want a
particular type of crunch
oh okay [ __ ]
depending on the sandwich you you know
you need different bacon textures
true blt you want it more on the crispy
side if you're having a bacon egg and
cheese on a fresh geyser roll
you're gonna want like a a bacon that
sort of contours and
complements the yeah it can be [ __ ]
gentlemen can be too dry and crunchy on
a bacon again i'll never forget i had
barry ribs came and crashed with me in
la
and he still to this day talks to me
about the bacon naked cheese
[Laughter]
um have you ever had a manicure yes do
you get them
regularly or like so i stopped biting my
nails when i turned 30 i was like
i'm done really and then i got on a
plane and it was very turbulent
and i said [ __ ] that your nails yeah
yeah so while i was
not biting my nails i'd go in mani pedi
but uh
that's nice okay that's i never had one
ever use a shoe horn no all right have
you ever used bounty wrinkle release
dryer sheets no like the spray that gets
the wrinkles out
no okay everything in a quiz no
yeah yo quiznos ain't too shabby really
carbonaro
because they are good too
yeah they are tasty and they're quite i
say quiznos is garbage
i can't stand the smell of subway really
dude how's my next question
i wasn't gonna ask you've ever ate at a
subway but have you ever had your
sandwich heated up at a subway i've
gotten a toasted sub yeah see that's
garbage italian herb and cheese with the
spicy bee
the spicy italian i would do a chicken
parm from subway
yeah not proud what the [ __ ] extra
provolone and bacon on that [ __ ]
i'll tell you what they used to not do
pretty pretty shabby was their meatball
sub was okay
yeah their meatballs and [ __ ] stuff
so hard to [ __ ] up with meatball sub
it's
it's true you start with good meatballs
that's the dice you're rolling but the
sauce can save you even if they're not
that good
have you ever collected or carried
pocket knives
i don't know if i'd call it a collection
but i definitely carried
yeah i think i got one on me now no i
don't um
yeah i carry pocket knives ever do
karate in public
in the class really tiger shulman's
well i enrolled in tiger shulman's
recently what
come on i swear they're like creamer in
that episode
well no my class this is the [ __ ] up
part my class was all black belts my
first day
and i was like yeah i'm not in the right
class because uh
i watched a bunch of cobra kai on
netflix oh and i was like i need to
train
see this is what i think that's like new
money [ __ ] where he's like i gotta i
gotta get an instructor to teach me how
to [ __ ]
how to defend
are you still going uh twice a week
you're going to tiger shulman
it's not twice a week it's mma now
that's a little different
i wanted to go to karate but it's full
on mma is it tiger shulman's
yes so they've switched over from just
karate to mma
tiger shulman's mma and my sensei lyman
good
was a bellator fighter for a while now
he's doing ufc this
i i wanted to make jokes but this [ __ ]
kick ass
oh yeah for sure those dudes don't like
that bad [ __ ] man
i shout out to sensei lyman good are
there kids in your class no
i mean there's a does this kid he was
doing the most with the
like we were supposed to do like uh
strength training exercises like squats
and [ __ ]
and he would jump and clap after every
squat and i was like you're showing off
yeah there's nobody here mm-hmm what do
you do you have the ghee
and then it's not a key it's like these
uh these karate pants
and then a tiger shulman's t-shirt and a
white belt that i wrote black lives
matter
it was too white
[Laughter]
they gave up on the ghee huh yeah casual
friday
it's not right but you're wearing a
tiger soulman's shirt to tiger shulman's
it's the uniform it's the uniform the
shoes like you can't do it in another dc
what are we talking about barefoot like
someone in metallica wearing a metallica
shirt
but like okay do you wear jeans to the
pool
sometimes yeah in the pool sometimes
that's garbage yeah i'm swimming cut off
jean shorts
i'm swaming my shirt gesture what do you
mean like
nothing no bottom because there was some
hot ladies there and i was like
i'm not ready for this yeah but you see
that you look at it you look even worse
you gotta [ __ ] roll the dice it's a
that's a you gotta just own it
that brings it that's another question
do you own a bathing suit now if you're
going to go swimming you got a bathing
suit you're going in like
shorts i own a couple of bathing suits
okay nice you're going to tuxedo right
now
do i have a tuxedo yeah you own one
several or
really tux's suits yeah yeah your suit
game's [ __ ] on point
that's a big one that's a big question
we ask is if like something were to
happen you have a job interview or a
funeral go to tomorrow yeah do you have
a suit you can put on and by you are
[ __ ] he's got autism
dirty suits yeah okay you come in after
a day of work shooting hq
you're coming
hq i rarely wear the suit pants yeah
because it's from the waist out
nobody knows that's even close he's got
his karate pants on
i did that twice
came straight from the dojo had to ask
12 questions he's got his tiger pants on
um when was the last time you bought a
40
oh my uncle jeff had passed away
and i know him and my dad he was my
dad's cousin they used to go
to the beach and they had this thing
called the great pumpkin
and they would take whatever liquors
they had pour it in the pumpkin
and just pass around this communal
pumpkin and get [ __ ] up on the beach
so it's my dad and all my like uncles
and
older cousins at the funeral i went and
bought a bunch of 40s and we came back
and celebrated
that's pretty close an actual pumpkin or
a plastic it was like a plastic pumpkin
ah that's pretty cool trick or treating
yeah i don't know why they brought it to
the beach they didn't have like a punch
bowl
that's nice that's pretty that's good
though as long as you're not buying them
to like sit in your house and drink food
yeah yeah what was the last 30 though
was last time they had a four loko or a
nose
what's it called nos nos i don't the
last time i had a four loko was at the
height of the protest okay in the summer
no i think it was a little before yeah
yeah it wasn't okay in the spring yeah
i've had one shockingly recently as well
i
i remember when he had it with his
[ __ ] meatball sub from subway
high school i was pouring four lokos
into coffee cups and drinking them shits
in class
jesus what are you a divorce dad what
the [ __ ] you're drinking in school
yeah man i needed to to get through all
that shakespeare
when was the last time you used an atm
just to check
your balance
i haven't done that long i got the app
excellent yeah excellent
and second part of the question have you
ever gotten cash back when you make a
purchase
um accidentally ah i hit yes
kid's a [ __ ] gentleman i hate yes the
other day at the [ __ ] uh
where was i tj maxx oh jesus
i'm a maxinista baby they have so many
socks
and 90s nickelodeon nostalgic t-shirts
yeah uh but yeah i hit yes accidentally
and the
chick gave me twenty dollars i was like
what is this she was like that's yours i
was like why
oh i don't know it was like a mystery
shopkins
special tj maxx promotion and she was
like you started coming down
i was like i did it uh
all right have you ever been to an olive
garden yes bread lobster
of course okay i'm black have you ever
been to a pet i didn't want to ask
number one graduation dinner get those
biscuits going red lobster or sizzler
man
anytime you graduate from something
you're getting some cheddar baked
biscuits man i [ __ ] love this
scissors
i don't think i've ever been i ain't
been to sizzler in a minute but red
lobster
i ordered red lobster during the
quarantine
to the house yep what'd you get uh
shellfish doesn't travel well no i mean
it it's 15 minutes away
oh that's not bad yeah it was awesome it
was good
yeah i want to get back to a red lobster
80 dollars of red lobster on uber
i was ready to complain if something was
wrong
i had to figure this out
[Laughter]
let me check this back hey i'll be right
with you one second
okay
yes it does okay all right i think we
just got a couple more questions here
mm-hmm what do you got uh have you ever
been to a pawn shop
yes have you ever pawned anything that's
when you put it in
yes no okay never sold anything to them
or bought anything i've bought [ __ ] from
a pumpkin shop i just went in because i
was watching
pawn stars and i was like let me see if
they got some [ __ ]
and i went in and i asked the guy i was
like y'all selling the jewelry here and
he's like not like the fake [ __ ] you're
wearing
jesus that was before i got real real
yeah i bought a guitar at a pawn shop
and then i
sold the that same guitar back to that
pawn shop no doubt
at a lesser price yeah i was gonna say
that the margins didn't hold up on that
one
have you ever made nachos in the
microwave no
what do you keep your ketchup in the
refrigerator or in the cabinet do not
own ketchup
really why not children because of your
dad thing no
just don't [ __ ] eat ketchup because i
wasn't sure if it was bad memories no
you don't use ketchup no bruh what do
you put on your scrambie eggs in the
morning
besides [ __ ] i cook them in a little
butter
and then i [ __ ] throw some hot sauce
no ketchup ew
what mayonnaise i have mayonnaise
mustard
i have three types of mustard three
types of mustard yellow
spicy brown and uh this mustard i got
from a
kosher deli it's like i know the name of
it i know exactly what you're talking
about
it's almost like a german mustard kind
of yeah i have
uh two types of sauerkraut in the fridge
right now damn
okay probiotics man pretty classy
now when you do order takeout said you
know red lobster
well you plate it or will you eat out of
the i eat i'm not trying to do more
dishes
i just ordered tacos yesterday tinfoil
no bueno
do you take leftovers home from a
restaurant uh
no wait my man hit me jack i've never
[ __ ] not finished yes of course
really
i don't remember the last time i ate
something that you didn't i didn't
finish
yeah it's crazy talk that's that's
that's i didn't get this belly that's
women's [ __ ] leaving food for later
interesting wow i think you're going to
be all right
dog that [ __ ] and i don't get up from
the table until i'm done
just starving kids in africa foley my
last question is growing up
did you have breakfast did you have milk
with dinner
no really i thought only white people
did that
hey hey hey and not all white people all
right
only real trashy ones well you are you
telling me
that the tanners were trash
yeah there was 15 of them [ __ ] guys
living in the house that ain't classy
they had they had to have nine parents
paying the mortgage on that thing
i mean after after the mom passed away
who was a tanner
she wasn't yeah they were trash
who knows what she was up to she was the
friendly quirky neighbor that would stop
by to
she would say she was selling pills come
on
i didn't trust that kid as well she was
she was [ __ ] getting high on her own
supplies
yeah you know john stamos was doing a
little up in that room
[ __ ] cleaning the rock i just caught
that they were trash that was like
such a cool family dynamic they had the
dog comet
that dog was great the fact that uncle
jesse lived downstairs and had like a
recording studio down there like yeah
with rippers dude that was the coolest
[ __ ] thing to me and i remember
the one episode there was a light on it
was like don't come down when this red
light's on i'm like
man i want a red light in my house you
want that in your room for when you're
when you're pulling your pud
yeah would make you laugh i'd talk
forever was that a song jesse in the
room yeah justin the rivers
uh what was the uh what was the
guitarist name that uh
dj dated or not yeah steve was it steve
i don't know if steve played guitar but
he played football yeah not steve but
then she did it like viper so it was
like something so on the nose
yeah it was like a viper or a snake or
something
it was real bad all right i got one last
one what is growing up what
is or now at any time what is your
favorite type of frozen pizza
i can't answer i live in new york yeah
frozen pizza in new york is sacrilegious
i don't know i still get it i just had
one stover's friend bread
people spread people were talking the
other day in the facebook group about
uh digiorno's croissant crusted
that's come on i went to get one what
two nights ago
but they didn't have it at the grocery
store but they did have their pan pizza
which is like their sicilian i feel like
i'm never man
never more than like four blocks from a
decent place yeah you know sometimes
just want frozen pizza
[ __ ] no yeah maybe that's so good i
don't know man i never
caught myself craving a pizza that i had
to wait a half hour
[Laughter]
that's pretty good that's what i go to
uh you know any one of the pieces in
15 minutes and they get a fresh ass pie
true
maybe it's a suburban thing i don't know
but sometimes i just crave
like like a frozen like actual frozen
pizza i don't even like tostino's pizza
you better get the hell out of here get
the doorman to kick him the [ __ ] out of
here jesus christ
throwing you out like jazzy jeff start
trashing totino's
i mean i think what's the verdict on
this one i think it's pretty classy
right oh yeah there's nothing
there's nothing lean in trash i think
that's just because you guys asked the
wrong questions
i don't know i mean you've definitely
done trashy [ __ ] oh yeah questionable
behavior but that doesn't make you a
there's a difference between
you know doing shitty things or trashy
things or sexually permanent
there's nothing wrong with that no um
but i think i mean you know you had a
solid upbringing
you know i mean you got some you know a
little bit of the new money thing but
that's fine
but everything i'm just enjoying life
man yeah can't come at you for the pets
we can't i can't get you on the phone
you do the pets right
i think it's a little too many pets but
you do them right as soon as i leave
here we're going back to the dog park
and then i got to go to the fish store
to pick up some uh reverse osmosis
deionized water
jesus christ i know a guy who can get
you out on the street
who makes that pellegrino
uh buddy is there anything you want to
promote anything you got coming up [ __ ]
uh hey everybody play hq trivia we're
back
there you go seven nights a week at 9 00
pm
get on it peeps get on it and what's
your social
matt was funny that was funny on all
platforms
except tick tock tick tock it's matt
richards 808 i was going through a phase
where i thought i was going to be a
music producer
i bought a little beat machine little
mini keyboard
thing i was trying to make beats that's
what that's what i did people were
scrambling over the coin
cooking shows i didn't know what i was
doing man i was like i gotta figure out
something
comedy has gone for the foreseeable
future i'm about to make a beat
oh my god that's awesome give me what do
they got to know out there uh as always
please make sure you rate review
subscribe on itunes
uh tell a friend about the show we're
[ __ ] cooking with gas over here yes
sir or you know now that the studio is
up and running
um patreon guys if you want to support
the show you can go to patreon.com
are you garbage there's three different
levels you can choose and also too like
we said before we get hit up so many
times
uh with people submitting their own
questions for us to ask that if you do
join up for patreon we will 100
answer your question uh or ask your
question you know to a guest or if we do
a
a host episode or whatever um we will
definitely get to it and you'll get
bonus
episodes every week you'll get a bonus
episode of hard feelings every week and
we're going to be doing videos
and [ __ ] like that so sign up do it
very nice and gang comment on the
youtube youtube page
if there's a guest that you want to see
on the podcast please reach out to us
uh tweet about it and stuff like that
and uh we'll try to make it happen we
love you and we'll see you next week i
thought patreon was for like selling
feet pics
no that's uh only fans
onlyfans.com kevin ryan
come get these feet backslash h foley's
butthole see you guys